the kingdom of the two sicilies famous
for having only one sicily this is
obviously one of the most bare-faced
lies in human history alongside i
promise i don't want any more of
czechoslovakia and i'll be home soon
sweetie and given that to everybody
alive ever even dave the name was
obviously incorrect why did it have this
name why did the kingdom of the two
sicilies only have one sicily well in
order to find out we need to go back to
the medieval period by the mid-12th
century the southern italian peninsula
in sicily had been united under the
normans soon after one of the holy roman
emperors inherited the kingdom and
promptly fell out with the pope who then
agreed to a french prince taking the
kingdom which he soon did as charles the
first and twenty years later the people
on sicily came to a realization this
king kind of sucks and so rebellion the
rebels asked for protection from king
peter of arrogant who was happy to
accept free land and peasants to work it
this obviously led to war between the
two kings and charles challenged peter
to a jewel which peter accepted on the
condition that it be held in english
held france and king edward the first of
england refereed now obviously this
would have been amazing which is why it
could never happen edward wanted nothing
to do with this because he was too busy
invading his neighbours long story short
there was a lot of war and in the end it
was agreed that peter's second born son
could have sicily but not him peter then
died his heir then died shortly
afterwards and everything went to his
second son anyway so everybody died for
nothing and this is where the kingdom of
sicily was broken up the arrogance kept
the kingdom of sicily which now only
contained sicily and the french kept the
rest of southern italy which did not
contain any sicily this wasn't going to
stop its rulers from keeping the name
though and with that there were two
kingdoms of sicily these two kingdoms
remained separate until the early 16th
century which was when king ferdinand
and queen isabella of castile and leon
conquered the south and all of these
soon became a part of the kingdom of
spain but there were still separate
entities from each other in terms of
governance these two kingdoms would
trade hands a couple more times before
it was time for the french revolution at
this point the sicilies were ruled by
king ferdinand iv who was a firm
opponent of these new ideas whilst
napoleon was busy doing his thing
ferdinand pushed north to remove the
french from the peninsula this went
incredibly well for the french who soon
pushed him out of the peninsula and
probably deposed him from one of his
sicilies as you'll all know napoleon
eventually got sick of success and tried
his hand at losing which led to the
victorious european powers trying to
reset the continent at the congress of
vienna unsurprisingly ferdinand wanted
his kingdom back and so sent delegates
to petition for his restoration cleverly
ferdinand didn't want to be restored as
the king of sicily and the king of
sicily but as the king of the kingdom of
the two sicilies this was because he
wanted to reform and centralize his
kingdom but as two separate kingdoms
there were powers he had in one realm
that he lacked in the other with his
restoration to a brand new kingdom he
could rewrite the constitution and
centralize power and this would be
backed by the great powers and so after
this the kingdom of the two sicilies
would remain a part of the european
family until its eventual conquest into
italy 45 years later thereby ending
perhaps the worst named kingdom ever i
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with a special thanks
to my patrons james bissonette kelly
moneymaker corso wolff jordan longley
adam stalter jerry landon marcus
arsenault wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
words about books podcast gustav swan
captain cydog roddy martin common yoon
boogery wiggly mrs et marvin cassow
aaron the white matthew shipley alex
schwinn maggie patzkowski anthony
beckett maxon flaudio the mcwhopper
corey turner spinning three plates
copper tone winston k wood charles the
first and scottish trekkie